-Hey, guys, it is Friday,
and that's usually when
I take care of some business.
You know,
I get some things done.
But the day just
completely got away from me.
I spent all day watching
YouTube videos of
people eating ghost peppers.
And I completely forgot to write
out my weekly thank-you notes.
And I know it's during the show,
but do you guys mind if
I write out some
thank-you notes right now?
Is that okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Appreciate it.
James, can you help me out
when you can?
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you,
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris,
for making us all feel like
mom and dad just got home
after having
the worst babysitter ever.
"You wouldn't believe
what happened."
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, Hot Pockets recalling
760,000 pounds of product
due to broken glass in it,
for being the first time
anyone has ever
cared what's in a Hot Pocket.
Sausage Meat Lover -- Whatever.
Just microwave it.
It tastes good.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, playoff game between
Tampa Bay and Green Bay.
Regardless of who wins,
at least I can still say...
Oh, yeah.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, vending machines
with COVID home tests,
for being the only time
a vending-machine purchase
has positively affected
my health.
Mm...
We did another one about
the COVID vending machines.
This was a good --
It was a good subject.
No, I mean
I'm about to write it,
my thank-you note, again, yeah.
-Oh, okay. Just came to you.
-Same address.
-Yeah.
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, vending machines
with COVID home tests,
for explaining why
I just saw someone
trying to stick
a Twix bar up their nose.
Come on. Come on.
Do I have tissues here?
I do.
Ah-ah-choo!
[ Laughs ]
[ Breathes deeply, sneezes ]
Whew!
It always comes in fours.
[ Breathes deeply, sneezes ]
[ Laughter ]
-What the heck is your problem?
-Yeah.
-My jeans came with no pockets.
[ Breathes deeply, sneezes ]
[ Laughs ]
-What is going on?
-[ Laughing ] Here we go.
Alright.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, transition lenses,
for letting me feel like
I have a superpower
where I transform into
a European deejay.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, Dr. Scholl's
foot machines at drugstores,
for being the
"Dance Dance Revolution"
for 60-year-olds with bunions.
[ Beat-boxing ]
♪♪
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, avocado pits,
for showing me how
Skee-Balls are born.
There you go, everybody.
Those are our "Thank You Notes."